President Carter said in this very site
that he thinks America is ready for for
a gay president polls have shown that
there is a Vanity Fair CBS poll that
showed over fifty percent of the public
supports the concept of an openly gay
president we've certainly you know
emerged as a as a political force in
this country you're seeing a lot of
attention to the issues we just passed
Don't Ask Don't Tell repeal and so I
think the timing is absolutely perfect I
think the fact that I am an outsider
that that I've been in the political
process for over thirty years I've
worked on nine presidential campaigns
I've been very high level at three I
think I think that shows that the public
is is ready and and my experience
particularly the political side of
things but as a washing outsider I think
would be unique and be welcomed
I'm not so sure how how some of the far
right wing people will react to my
candidacy I am considering myself an
independent Republican I'm more
progressive particularly on some of the
social issues than than anybody else
considering running so there might be
some opposition I actually faced my
first bit of hatred when I was in Iowa
in may I had had reception there as I've
done in New Hampshire many times this
was my first in Iowa after that the
republican national committeeman a man
named steve scheffler also happens to be
president of the Iowa christian alliance
sent me a very terse threatening email
and it said you and the radical
homosexual community are not welcome in
Iowa and as a matter of fact I will work
overtime and interesting choice of words
to abort your candidacy well you know
this is from the number two ranking
Republican in the state of Iowa and and
I turned that over the Des Moines
Register and it became a huge news story
there and a lot of comments everyone
defended my my right to be in that Iowa
caucus if I choose to do so so you know
I think if people are going to attack me
strictly because I happen to be gay I
think that that will backfire